sony's market value dropped by 20
billion dollars after microsoft's big
acquisition battlefield 2042 just
dropped another big patch and more
microsoft's 68.7 billion dollar deal to
acquire activision blizzard sent
shockwaves through the industry this
week even reaching far enough to
seemingly shake up sony's worth on the
global market sony group corp share fell
by as much as 13
after the microsoft deal was made public
effectively wiping out 20 billion off
sony's valuation this was the largest
dip in the japanese conglomerate share
price since october 2008 back when the
company recalled a hundred thousand
laptop batteries due to potential fire
hazard issues
in contrast to sony's rocky tuesday
japanese publishers such as capcom and
konami and square enix saw their stock
rise by more than five percent on
tokyo's financial markets a sign that
companies with strong video game ips
were likely to become more valuable in
an age of mega acquisitions french
publisher and developer ubisoft also
experienced a surge in its stock price
which rose by 11 by the time the markets
had closed for more on the biggest news
story of the week you can check out our
features such as every ip that microsoft
just bought in its activision blizzard
acquisition the internet's reaction to
the bombshell announcement and more over
on gamespot.com
dice has released the full patch notes
for battlefield 2042's next big update
the 3.2 update is releasing on january
20th and it includes bug fixes and
stability improvements mainly included
in the patch are raising the xp cap on
portal that took a hit at launch from
players exploiting custom matches fixes
for a hit registration issue and
instances of rubber banding in some
scenarios being improved the patch also
addresses an issue where players could
become stuck in a loop between being
downed but still alive dice said in a
statement that this update is part of
our continued commitment to address your
feedback related to resolving bugs and
improving gameplay again the 3.2 update
for battlefield 2042 goes live on
january 20th and it's a zero downtime
update so players can jump right in
after the download finishes a size for
the install however was not announced
after this another update is coming in
february for battlefield 2042 that's
going to include some quality of life
improvements in new features including
the long-awaited new scoreboard ui but
still no voice chat we also have the
full list of patch notes on our site
right now
with only a few more weeks before it
arrives sony has released a brand new
trailer for horizon forbidden west
unlike the other trailers that focused
on tribes hostile mechanical wildlife
and robots with impressive swimming
skills the latest trailer focuses on
just what spurs ailoy to embark on a new
adventure and the dangers that lie
hidden in the sinister landscape of
forbidden west the trailer shows a
strange blight that has begun sweeping
across the world and killing off all
life machines have begun to grow more
aggressive towards humans and the key to
saving the world lies in the forbidden
west eloy will have to explore this
unknown region and in the process she'll
encounter regala described as a warrior
who seeks to slaughter all those who
have wronged her and will kill anyone
who gets in her way pretty much like
every villain ever made but let's roll
with it regala is voiced by angela
bassett and will battle aeloy throughout
the course of the game the real twist in
the trailer though is that horizon zero
dawn's nomadic researcher silence has
returned and is pulling several strings
behind the scenes aloy won't be alone in
her quest though as her allies errand
and varl will lend her a hand from time
to time other new faces include the
tinath tribe warrior kotalo the curious
explorer alva who hails from an unknown
tribe and the uttaru tribes zou lastly
the trailer confirms that artificial
intelligence gaia will also return while
another character by the name of tilda
will be brought to life by the matrix's
very own carrion moss horizon forbidden
west is launching on ps4 and five on
february 18th which is officially less
than a month away
february is going to be full of releases
but what are you looking forward to the
most and why let me know in the comments
and of course leave a like subscribe and
make sure you tune in tomorrow for your
next gamespot news update we'll see you
later